- What is that?
- That's the baby's buttocks.
She's breech.
- Oh, thank God, I
thought she had two heads.
- Oh God.
(audience laughs)
- Let's have a little
fun today and check out
one of my favorite shows
of all time, Friends.
There's some medical scenes on
there that are questionable,
and I wanna review them with you.
Let's get started.
Peewoop!
- Am I interrupting?
- Oh no, Dr. Long, please come in.
This is Ross.
He is the father.
- But not the husband because evidently,
she can do this alone.
- I really felt like
I was Ross growing up.
I was the geek, I was the nerd,
and I've always loved Rachel.
- There's your uterus, and right here
is your baby.
- Oh my God.
- Always a really powerful moment
when parents get to see
the heartbeat of the baby.
I would usually show the
chambers and the heart beating.
Family gets really excited.
It's a special place to be
when you're delivering a baby.
As a family medicine
doctor, I no longer do it,
even though I'm licensed and I know how.
I've delivered 38 babies in residency.
(Rachel whimpers)
- Pretty amazing, huh?
- I've seen Friends so many times.
I know what she's crying about.
- I don't see it.
(audience laughs)
- It's so funny, nowadays,
it would be less of an issue
because we have like these 3-D ultrasounds
that can actually show
the face of the baby.
We can print out the pictures
and then the parents go show
them around to their families.
It's really cute.
- Hi, hi, this is Rachel Green.
I'm Ross Geller.
We, we called from the car.
- Right, we have a semi-private
labor room waiting for you.
So we're just gonna...
- Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, I'm sorry, semi-private?
We, we, (laughs) we
asked for a private room.
- Yes, I see that here.
Unfortunately, we can't
guarantee a private room,
and currently they're all unavailable.
- Hospitals, especially in big
cities, like New York City,
they run out of rooms quickly.
So sometimes, especially
when you first arrive,
you can get only a semi-private room,
and then whoever has the most seniority,
who's been at the hospital the longest,
they may shift you around and
move you to a private room.
- Check these out.
- Uh-huh.
(audience laughs)
- It's a funny position for Ross.
Back in the day, these
used to be called stirrups.
We tend not to use that word anymore
'cause weird connotations.
We now call them leg rests
or ankle rests or foot rests.
- Who's that?
- New people.
(audience chuckles)
- When it's your first pregnancy,
statistically, it takes longer.
You have a longer labor.
If someone's coming in for
their third or fourth baby,
usually the process a lot quicker.
So you're gonna have multiple roommates
if it's your first.
- You listen to me, since
I have been waiting,
four women, that's four,
one higher than the number of
centimeters that I am dilated,
have come and gone with their babies.
I'm next.
It's my turn.
It's only fair.
- When she says she's
three centimeters dilated,
what she's talking about is
the opening of the cervix.
That's the opening of the uterus.
The way we monitor the
progression of labor
is through doing an estimate measurement,
usually through a digital
exam, using our fingers,
to see what that dilation is.
And three centimeters dilated
is really early in the labor process.
(Rachel groans)
- Push.
(Rachel pants)
Gonna push for five more seconds.
- My favorite part of this is the resident
or medical student, just standing there.
That is so accurate. (laughs)
They just stand there aimlessly,
like, "what should I do?
"I'm learning."
That was me back in the day.
That was all of us.
The one thing is, I don't
know why the doctor's
not wearing a mask.
We wear masks.
- Wait, I see something.
- What'd you do, you do?
Oh my God!
- Don't say oh my God.
Oh my God, what?
- What is that?
- It's the baby's buttocks.
She's breech.
- Oh thank God, I thought
she had two heads.
- Oh God.
(audience laughs)
- Breech means the baby is
coming out not head first,
coming out butt first,
which is problematic.
You want the baby to come down
and descend the canal head first.
A breech has a high rate of complications.
It's gonna be a tricky delivery,
especially if it's this far along.
But I love that Ross took
a look and did not faint
because a lot of fathers,
when they take a look,
they're not ready to see
everything that's going on.
They get a vasovagal reaction
where blood pressure drops,
not enough circulation,
not enough blood flow getting
to the head and they go wham.
I always have my nurses
keeping an eye on the dads
while the mom's delivering.
- You're gonna have to push even harder.
Nothing's happening.
- I'm sorry, I can't.
I can't.
- Yes you can.
Hey, hey, come on, you can.
I know you can do this.
Let's go.
- I can't, no, I...
Please, you do it for me.
- No.
(audience laughs)
- What they're missing here is
the mom shouldn't just
be pushing aimlessly.
She should be doing it
along with the contraction.
So it should be time.
We get to see the baby
monitor on the side.
When we see the contraction
starting, mom should feel it,
and at that point, we should
have the mom bear down,
push, count, and maybe
give a second effort there.
But they're just, looks like
they're pushing aimlessly.
(Rachel laughs)
- That is not a newborn baby. (laughs)
- Oh, she, she's perfect.
- Oh, wow.
Oh, she's so tiny.
Where'd she go?
- So we always try and get
the baby on the mom's chest
as fast as possible.
We feel like the best
sort of effects happen
when the baby gets right
on the mom's chest.
Mom calms down, it helps
lower her blood pressure,
slow the heart rate down, baby feels mom.
It's like nature at its finest.
And while mom is holding the baby,
then we let the father step
in and cut the umbilical cord.
Dads panic when they
cut the umbilical cord,
'cause it's kind of rubbery
and it takes a little bit of force
and they don't wanna hurt anything,
so they're really worried about doing it.
It's really cute to
watch, and I love that.
That's like one of my favorite parts,
getting the dad involved to do something.
- Hi, you're going into what grade?
(audience laughs)
- I'm actually a first year
resident, but I get that a lot.
See, I graduated early.
- Uh-huh, uh, me too.
- That's me every time in the hospital.
What are you, 10?
Are you in kindergarten?
What grade are you in?
Are you like Doogie Howser?
Then occasionally someone'd
be like, wow, you're young.
That means you must be smart,
and I was like, thank you.
- Mr. Tribbiani, I'm afraid
you've got kidney stones.
- Oh, well, what else could it be?
- It's kidney stones.
- To diagnose kidney stones,
sometimes we do an x-ray like that.
Better tests, which we
tend to do more often,
would be a CT scan with
very specific parameters.
We could also get an ultrasound.
All those are options.
- Better, sweetie?
- Maybe a little.
Wish you hadn't seen me throw up.
- Sometimes the pain can get so bad
that it can lead you to vomit.
I'm gonna give you a
little revelation here.
I've passed kidney stones before.
When I was really young,
didn't drink a lot of water.
I drank a lot of soda and I
passed one of these stones
and they were tiny, tiny,
tiny, but boy did it hurt.
There was blood.
Oh my God, if you ever have
to pass one, I'm sorry,
'cause it's not a fun experience.
So I sympathize with my patients
and I empathize with my man, Joey, here.
- Now ordinarily, Mr. Tribbiani,
we try to break the stones
up with shock waves,
but they're too close to the bladder now,
which means we can either
wait for you to pass them
or else go up the urethra.
- Whoa, whoa.
(audience laughs)
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Nothing is going up, okay?
Up, up is not an option.
What's a urethra?
(laughs)
- Actually, up is sometimes an option
and sometimes it's something we have to do
to inspect the bladder.
Another potential option for patients
who are looking to pass stones
is giving them a medication
to help in that process
to relax the smooth muscles of that area.
- Oh my God.
You did it, man.
(audience laughs)
- Would you like to see them?
- They're so small.
- They're not that small.
Those are fairly big size.
- I was in the shower and
as I was cleansing myself,
I, I, I, well, I felt something.
- Was it like a sneeze only better?
(audience laughs)
- No, no, I mean, I
mean a thing on my body.
- What was it?
- Well, I (sighs) I don't know.
It's, it's kind of in a place that's not,
it's not visually accessible to me,
and I was hoping maybe you
guys could, could help me out.
- Whoa!
- Hey!
- (laughs) That's funny,
'cause random people
tend to approach me and show
me their lesions quite often.
I cannot imagine how
dermatologists must feel.
- That's not a third nipple.
- Oh?
- First of all, it's on your ass.
(audience laughs)
- Doctors don't say that.
- Johnson would you come in here a moment?
- [Johnson] I'm with Hamilton.
- He's good with weird things.
Bring him in, too.
(audience laughs)
- It's funny, because anytime
you have a rare condition
in a hospital, you're gonna get residents,
specialists, fellows, everyone coming in.
Not only to help the
case, but also to learn
because we learn from our
patients as much as we help them.
(Ross groans)
- You okay, Ross?
- I don't know. (groans)
(audience laughs)
What's in this pie?
- I don't know, butter and eggs and flour
and lime and kiwi.
- Kiwi, kiwi?
You said it was a key lime pie.
- No, I didn't, I said kiwi lime.
That's what makes so special.
- That's what's gonna kill me.
(audience laughs)
- I'm allergic to kiwi.
- Ross is experiencing
an anaphylactic attack.
His upper airway is literally swelling.
It's closing up.
That can be quite dangerous quite quickly.
He also has dilation of
all of his blood vessels,
which drops your blood
pressure quite rapidly.
Your heart rate usually
springs up to compensate
for this loss of pressure.
But sometimes the blood pressure effects
can lead you to faint, vomit,
feel awful, have a headache,
and you desperately need to get to a place
that has an epinephrine auto injector.
- No, you're not.
You're allergic to lobster and peanuts.
(Ross groans)
(laughs)
- This reminds me of the scene from Hitch.
(Hitch gags)
- Whoa, whoa, you all right?
- Oh, no, yeah.
- Is your tongue swelling up?
- Either that or my
mouth is getting smaller.
(audience laughs)
- Both.
- All right, get your coat.
We're gonna go to the hospital.
- You really should call
911 in these situations
because the ambulance will arrive,
usually with an epinephrine
auto injector on board,
and they could administer
it if they need to.
The last thing you want is to get in a car
and then the swelling gets worse
and then your throat closes up in the car
and you don't know what to do.
So call 911 for help.
Even if you actually give yourself
an epinephrine auto injector,
you should still head to the ER.
20% of the time, you may need
either a second injection
or other interventions because
the first one has failed.
You also need to be monitored
after give yourself epinephrine.
Your heart rate, your blood
pressure, all of that.
- There's no way I'm gonna
get a shot, all right?
Maybe they can take the needle, you know,
and squirt it into my
mouth, like a squirt gun.
- You have to give the shot.
You have to give it quickly,
way quicker than what
he's experiencing here.
And you have to give it
right in the anterior
lateral portion of your thigh.
That's when you get the most
absorption as fast as possible.
Remember, this is an emergency.
- You add a pinch of saffron,
it makes all the difference.
(audience cheers)
- This is partially the reason
I really wanted to be a doctor.
This scene, the admiration,
Monica and Rachel are giving my man George
and I forgot the other, John White?
Will?
Noah Wiley.
(hands clap)
Getting all this attention.
I wanted it, mostly because
no one paid attention to me.
Not 'cause I was huge ego.
- You're gonna walk over
to the operating table.
You're gonna stop on that blue mark.
You're gonna put the tray down.
Don't walk too fast, but don't dawdle.
(audience laughs)
- Okay, now, what?
- If they're truly
operating on this patient,
why are all their masks down,
and why does Phoebe have no gloves on?
I don't like what's happening here.
I know this is a show inside
of a show inside of a show
and we're in inception land,
but I still get frustrated,
'cause I want you to
have an accurate picture
of what happens in a
hospital system, you dig?
Don't know what I'm doing,
but it feels like I'm
squaring up the conversation.
- How's it going?
- Going really good, but enough about me?
Come on. (laughs)
Where are you from?
What do you do?
(audience laughs)
- I'm a doctor.
- Right, right.
I'm actually, I meant, you
know, in your spare time,
do you cook, do you ski,
or just hang out with
your wife or girlfriend?
(audience laughs)
- I don't have a wife or
girlfriend, but I do like to ski.
- Oh, I love to ski!
How amazing is this?
- This conversation legitimately happens.
It happens more actually
in the hospital setting.
Patients are usually there overnight
or for several days at a time.
You get quite lonely, so they
wanna have a conversation.
But when it starts crossing
into that territory
where they're trying to
get into my personal life
and see if I'm single, that's
when it gets a little weird
and boundaries need to be set.
- So, are you experiencing any discomfort?
- No, I'm very comfortable.
- Oh my God, this reminds
me of my interview
that I just did on The
Daily Show not too long ago.
- How close is too close?
- Ideally you'd wanna keep six feet away
from anyone that you're not familiar with.
- Would this be too close?
- In my medical,
professional medical opinion,
I would say that's too close.
So six feet and then washing your hands.
- Is this too close?
- That would be too close.
- Too close.
- Awkward.
Here's two throwback
medical drama reviews.
ER, Doogie Howser.
Which one are you gonna watch?
Watch them both.
Mm, medical accuracy's not bad on both.
Which one are you watching?
As always, stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat music)